lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
si los resultados que nos dan la regla
de las potencias tienen sentido para
nada se trata de una demostración y más
bien se trata de hacerte sentir más
cómodo con esta regla
veamos si fx es igual a equis que dice
la regla de las potencias entonces f
prima de x se dan
en x el 1 está de manera implícita
entonces ponemos el 1 y es x al 11 que
es igual a una vez x a la 0 y esto es
igual a 1 y ahora esto tendrá sentido
desde el punto de vista conceptual
entonces voy a graficar estas funciones
a ver voy a empezar a poner mis ejes así
que aquí está el eje y aquí está el eje
x y ahora voy a graficar el fx así que
esto es igual a x se ve más o menos así
esto es igual a x si esto es que es
igual a x que bueno es lo mismo que fx
es igual a fx y entonces la derivada o
bueno mejor voy a poner que esto es
igual a fx mejor pongo fx es igual a
equis y bueno también pues es también la
pongo bueno y ahora voy a graficar la
derivada y ese es uno o sea para todos
los valores de x la derivada de su no
y esto es consistente con todo lo que
conocemos hasta ahora de derivadas y
pendientes ahora veamos la tangente de
nuestra función cual es la tangente en
este punto bueno pues es 1 en nuestra
función tiene pendiente 1 y no importa
qué valor tenga x es una línea la
pendiente vale 1 en este punto la
pendiente es 1 en este otro punto la
pendiente es 1 y si vamos a este otro
punto la pendiente es 1 así que tenemos
una respuesta válida
ahora probemos con algo en que la
pendiente cambia digamos que tengo gdx
que sea igual a x al cuadrado entonces
que nos dice la regla de las potencias
bueno pues n es igual a 2 entonces esto
será 2 veces x a la 2 menos 1 que es
igual a 2 veces x a la 1 que es 2x ahora
veamos si esto tiene sentido y entonces
voy a hacer la gráfica lo más preciso
que pueda bueno voy a tratar de
y graficar lo mejor posible
y vamos y vamos con los ejes trataré de
hacerlo lo más preciso posible este es x
este es la vera vamos con 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
3 4 y aquí 1 2 3 4 así que quede x
cuando x 0 0 cuando x es 1 vale 1 cuando
x es menos 1 vale 1 cuando x es 2 es
cuatro
y cuando x es menos dos es 4 y esto es
una parábola que ya la hemos visto por
mucho tiempo a ver este punto lo voy a
volver a acomodar de hecho voy a rehacer
estos últimos dos puntos entonces se ve
algo más o menos como esto
tiene que pasar por aquí y de este lado
bueno tiene que ser simétrico estoy
tratando de hacer lo mejor que puedo se
ve como esto bien esta es la gráfica de
gx igual a x al cuadrado bien ahora
vamos a graficar que prima de x o lo que
nos dice la regla de las potencias que
es g prima y es 2x pues es una línea que
pasa por el origen y tiene pendiente 2 y
se ve más o menos como esto cuando x
vale 1 pues gdx vale 2 y cuando x vale 2
pues gdx vale 4 entonces se ve más o
menos como voy a tratar de hacer mi
mejor línea recta posible y se ve como
esto
la pregunta es tiene sentido esto si
observamos la tangente de nuestra
gráfica y observamos este punto a ver
voy a usar un color que destaque y voy a
tratar de graficar lo mejor posible la
tangente y observamos que tiene una
pendiente alta y negativa y
efectivamente está muy inclinado y es
negativo entonces para x es igual a 2
entonces g prima a no no es para x igual
a menos 2 g prima de menos 2 es igual a
2 veces menos 2 que es igual a menos 4
esto nos dice que el valor de la
pendiente en este punto es menos 4 todo
indica que así lo es es un valor grande
y negativo el valor de m es igual a
menos 4 y se ve bien es una pendiente
bastante pronunciada y negativa y ahora
qué pasa en este punto cuando x vale 0
nos está diciendo que la pendiente de
nuestra función en x es igual a cero es
g prima de 0 que es igual a dos veces
cero
a 0 y tiene sentido si revisamos nuestra
parábola nuestra función original en el
vértice en 0 la pendiente 0 es el punto
mínimo ahí se ve que la pendiente es 0 y
ahora qué pasa cuando x vale 2 bueno
pues en este punto la pendiente se ve
pronunciada es positiva la tangente en
este punto es pronunciada y positiva y
que nos dice la derivada bueno
utilizando la regla de las potencias nos
dice que g prima de 2 o sea estamos
viendo cuál es el valor de la tangente
en ese punto entonces será dos veces 2
que es igual a 4 y entonces en este
punto la pendiente m es igual a 4 bueno
utilizo m porque es la letra que siempre
utilizamos para denotar la pendiente y
suena razonable bueno yo te invito a que
tomes puntos cercanos a este cálculo es
la pendiente y puedas comprobar que la
regla de las potencias proporciona
resultados que tienen sentido y funciona